hello everyone this is amir from
audiosounds review i have a professional
amplifier that i reviewed yesterday here
is the ashley in e8250
um it's a 8 channel amplifier and costs
fair bit for a pro amplifier twenty four
hundred dollars
um
and uh i suspect that's partially
because it has eight channels um it uh
got that sort of traditional look uh
obviously these things will be rack
mounted and not uh
you know put on a desk but but you can
and you can see my sample over here
and
the back connections are unusual uh for
our hi-fi industry but quite common in
custom install industry in that there
are all these phoenix blocks
um you can see an example in here so i
had to make my own connectors and xlr
connectors out of these guys not
difficult you just have to make sure you
get the pin one two and three correct uh
on this thing
um
uh the app is quite nice and functional
uh i should tell you that these controls
look analog in nature but they don't
they're not analogy i can actually turn
them for a while nothing changes and all
sudden clicks one db and unfortunately
you can't adjust
better than one db
so
as you can see i have a bit of channel
mismatch when i measured it and i could
not compensate for this either would go
too low or too high
the gain is a little bit on the low side
but pretty manageable 25 db i like to
see 29 db but when i set it to max it
stopped at 25 db so this amplifier is
getting a little bit of an advantage
compared to other amps that i test at 29
db
excuse me
the
biggest issue with this amplifier as
you'll see throughout the measurements
is this high level of distortion you can
see that you know that this spike is
around minus 58 db relative to our uh
main tone it's the third harmonic that's
that's quite loud and that sets our
synad which is the sum of noise and
distortion relative to our signal this
is quite uh poor if you look at the uh
uh all the amplifiers that i've tested
which i think is like 170 amplifiers
in last three years that it lands
squarely in the red section which is you
know quite poor uh you know anything
green is is fine and good and then blue
is exceptional so
we really have quite ways to climb in
here
i expect the noise performance to be
poor but this actually is not which is a
good thing some pro amps can be noisy
so at just 5 watts it has 15 bits of
dynamic range this beats a lot of
consumer amps
my target is 96 db but that requires
being in this blue category to usually
hit it and then when you turn it up at
the full volume the noise doesn't get
elevated as as much so it gives you 18
bits of dynamic range so it's high res
ready
i didn't quite like the frequency
response measurements on one hand and
like on another hand in that you can see
instead of being flat in 20 to 20
kilohertz which is what these two
cursors are uh it has uh somewhat
pronounced uh roll off about one and a
half db at 20 kilohertz and the roll off
doesn't stop till about five kilohertz
and then same with bass uh it rolls off
excuse me
down to you know two three db at 10
hertz so as a subwoofer amp you'll have
to compensate for that if you're going
to use it for that
the good news is that even though they
say it's class d when i um switch the
loads from forum to eight home the
frequency response did not change uh
many
less advanced class ds will then show an
overshoot uh or change in response when
i switch from forum to head home there's
no dependency in here so i don't know
that it's class d uh
but maybe it is i suspect it's maybe
more of a class g with a switching
amplifier
but i'll touch on that a little bit
later
crosstalk is good there are consumer
apps that don't do as well
multi-tone shows the problem again with
distortion and now we're you know if we
measure that in in bits equivalent we
get only 13 bits everything below 13
bits gets hammered and
lost in this intermodulation jungle
this is a very disappointing graph in
that we see that the
noise dominates here but unlike these
two other reference amps
distortion starts to dominate before you
even get to half a watt uh and it just
climbs and that's why five watts we had
poor performance and it gets a little
bit better but then it
skyrockets it tells me that it has a
very low level of feedback uh
and that gives us sort of a i don't know
if tube is the right board but it's the
same in some of the poorly designed
consumer amps that don't have as much
feedback so
um anyway so the distortion keeps
climbing
at some point it really clips and that's
about 312 watts but that's very high
distortion
it's so high that when i measure at just
one percent distortion we actually get
less power usually this is the other way
around
so spec is 250 we're getting 220 good
enough um it has no headroom because of
the switching power supplies are
regulated and so they're
you know peak power now and the
continuous power usually the same so
more or less we're at uh 240 watts
go to uh
excuse me at uh 8 ohm uh same problem
happens just distortion climbs
continuously and goes up so not very
good
uh a lot of those tests were one
kilohertz so let's sweep it at uh from
15 kilos down to 20 hertz and we see
this this interesting hump that happens
at all frequencies and gets worse at
higher frequencies this tends to tell me
there's some kind of rail switching
going on like class g class g runs the
amplifier at lower voltage when it
doesn't need as much power and then
switches to a higher voltage and
continues to provide more power and that
gives it efficiency and makes the heat
sink smaller
and
we see that hump in here or it could
also be you know class d designs have
all kinds of weirdness can go on with
them as far as their transfer functions
so
uh not great the whole graph is way up
here and then we have this hump in here
around four or five or ten watts which
is could be the average listening level
you have so you get more distortion at
five watts than you do at almost 200
watts
so
not good uh on this front so
uh instead of laboring the point you
know we can see that this this amplifier
is essentially a distortion factory for
its intended application of driving
uh background sound in a venue and what
have you nobody's going to care but for
hi-fi use i don't think it's that great
of a choice it's expensive at twenty
four hundred dollars
so for home theater could you use it but
yeah it's got copious amount of
distortion i've tested other pro amps
that have much better performance than
this um
anyway you have the data if you want to
buy it anyway uh i'm told the owner
bought it on ebay and then had this
thing serviced before sending it to me
so
now you have the full story okay i'll
make this short and sweet see you in a
future video bye bye